[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mardi 21 mai et
gravures à voie numérique ou encore
affiche les expositions sont multiples
dans le département en cette fin de mois
de mai focus sur trois d'antenne sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
jusqu'au 25 mai le festival de cannes
est sous le feu des projecteurs 21 films
sont en compétition
certains ont été financés par la région
ile-de-france envie de partir pour les
états unis ont vésinet c'est en musique
où vous invite à voyager le vésinet jazz
métis festival met à l'honneur quatre
groupes quatre styles elle s'offre une
sorte de rétrospective pour sa carte
blanche à un gravure saint quentin en
yvelines
jocelyne brise les a choisi de remonter
le temps dans ces 25 années de peinture
et de gravure
elle expose actuellement au sein même de
l'atelier de l'association à elancourt
500 ans après sa mort léonard de vinci
qui toujours les artistes
le peintre et hommes de science italien
est l'une des inspirations de jocelyne
brise les médias rembrandt
il y a
velasquez il y à goya beaucoup il ya
plusieurs références sur goya
il y a aussi dans lé content pour un
petit peu plus contemporain j'ai quand
même quelques petites références à
matisse je travaille sur le thème de la
référence
sur l'histoire de l'art
je prends soin les portraits peints trou
soit des extraits de leurs oeuvres et je
les retrouve parfois les retransforme où
je mets à une pointe d'humour ou une
note historique contemporaine
l'artiste mordasini créé depuis 25 ans
de la peinture à la gravure c'est le
thème qui conduit la création pour cette
exposition pensé comme une rétrospective
jocelyne brisé a choisi comme fil rouge
la couleur la couleur la chaleur de
cette couleur toutes les nuances qui
peut y avoir
et puis aussi à la symbolique de cette
couleur qui peut représenter la violence
le sang la joie aussi que tout de même
enfin mon quelque chose de fort quand
même c'est une couleur forte
une cinquantaine d'oeuvres sont
rassemblés au sein de l'atelier où elles
ont été créées un moyen pour l'artiste
d'initier les curieux à des techniques
parfois oubliées et le 26 mai c'est la
journée nationale de lestang tu à cette
occasion des démonstrations auront lieu
au sein de l'atelier d'art gravure 50
ans nîmes il est aussi prévu un
programme une lecture poétique sur le
thème de l'art et des artistes des
créations colorées au premier abord
joyeuse leur demande aime parler de
l'humanité de sa survie de la sueur
identités des individus mais aussi de
l'éventuel danger des machines
numériques et de leur omniprésence un
milieu numérique que manipulent
l'artiste christian il crée à l'aide de
son ordinateur des oeuvres qui peut
aussi peindre avec une première ébauche
numérique
ils exposent à l'espace puis priori des
clayes-sous-bois jusqu'au 2 juin
ce qui me plaît dans le numérique c'est
que c'est immédiat on peut faire ça très
vite
et en même temps ça peut prendre aussi
beaucoup de temps on peut on peut
facilement recommencer et on peut
essayer plein de choses
ça c'est la qualité première du
numérique on peut essayer des formes
différentes
on peut changer de calques on peut
changer de valeur dans le calque on peut
changer de couleur quand on veut on peut
gommer
on peut revenir en arrière un travail
minutieux qui la mène d'abord à
travailler pour la scala de milan
un surdoué qui expose dès l'âge de 14
ans luigi castiglioni est au coeur d'une
exposition au sein des archives
départementale des yvelines est avec
nous aurons gauthier bonjour vous êtes
médiatrice culturelle dit générer un
organisme rattaché au département êtes
en charge de cette exposition notamment
pourquoi m cet artiste à l'honneur alors
il ya eu une donation faite aux
départements par madame castiglione
inertie à castiglioni on à 180 oeuvres
au total avec affiches estampillées au
graphite tirages d'art c'est le pôle
sauvegarde de l'agencé le sauvegarder
transmission des patrimoines de l'agencé
ingénierie qui du coup a géré cette
donation que ce soit de de l'arrivée des
affiches jusqu'à l'inventaire
l'encadrement et le but justement
c'était 2 à travers cette exposition de
mettre en avant
le travail de luigi castiglioni mais
cette donation justement une donation
qui est pas anodine
il est donné 100 sites allen on comprend
bien que son nom mais les turinois
d'adoption c'est ça à partir des années
80 au tout début des années 80 il est
venu habiter avec tertia castilho ni à
maisons-laffitte une 40 rue puebla et on
peut aussi expliquer que cette maison
elle est visitable
c'est madame qu'est ce qui unit qui
accueille en fait les groupes à travers
son association les amis de logis
castiglioni donc à l'accueil ou
seulement par groupe il faut préciser
parce que c'est une maison dans laquelle
elle vit toujours en fait et il ya aussi
un projet qui est en cours qui fait que
la maison va être potentiellement
inscrits au titre des monuments
historiques et on travaille également
sur un label maison des illustres
donc ça c'est une affaire à suivre dans
cette exposition on voit principalement
des affiches et l'une d'entre elles va
faire son histoire et sa réputation
c'est d'un match de boxe cc 1972 c'est
ça c'est le match mais nous en images
ouais c'est le match monzon bouthier
en fait il y avait deux fosses abyssales
battini qui a qui a créé une exposition
pour lucky castiglioni et gérer ce match
au palais des sports de paris
et il lui a offert la possibilité en
fait de réaliser cette affiche en
invitant le directeur à choisir cette
affiche là pour ce qui va le lancer dans
presque métier d'un flûtiste et
notamment le sport ce que c'est un thème
récurrent dans ses oeuvres notamment
dans celles que vous vous avez choisi
ça va pas non c'est dans ce métier
d'affiché s'il en faisait déjà mais en
fait c'est cette affiche qui
particulièrement va le faire connaître
du grand public
en fait il était déjà connu des dans le
métier voilà mais c'est cette affiche
qui va le faire connaître du grand
public c'est vrai que le sport c'est à
80 % de ce qu'il a réalisé et la boxe
une énorme partie des ces affiches
sportives mais on peut filmer les touche
à tout il ya du tenait sur du foot et du
4 au 18 c'est ça il ya la fameuse
affiche
2 du championnat du monde et être un
dicton la france a gagné donc c'est vrai
qu'elle est très actuel il y à du tennis
il ya du vélo il ya aussi de la course à
pied et il ya même des pour les courses
hippiques
il ya une affiche qui représente une
course à maisons-laffitte ans quand on
regarde ces hommes on en vient presque à
douter que ce sont des dessins
t'annoncer précis il transformait
lui-même ses outils ses pinceaux il
trafique et son matériel
c'est ça alors il juste avant il faut
peut-être préciser aussi que chaque
affiche c'est un tableau à l'origine à
la base c'est toujours un tableau que ce
soit sur toile sur bois ou même sur
marbre parce qu'il travaille aussi la
peinture sur mare et effectivement ils
utilisent des outils très particulier il
prenait ce les pinceaux et lui enlever
la plupart de ses poils pendant l'essai
que deux ou trois et du coup c'est avec
ça qu'ils le bnia avec cette extrême
précision tous les petits détails de ses
tableaux alors dans cette expulsion peut
aussi découvrir un certain engagement il
il dessine pour le droit de vote le don
du sang mais aussi les boat people
il était très investi oui il était très
investi pour les causes humanitaires il
ya des associations qui vont de faire
appel à lui notamment médecins du monde
pour les boat people il ya aussi une
association rio de oro qui
vient en aide en fait aux réfugiés du
peuple saharaoui au début des années
2000 mais aussi des laboratoires
pharmaceutiques comme organe technique a
pour qui la fait la fiche du don du sang
au début des années 80 alors cette
exposition est visible aux archives
départementales
et pour ceux qui voudraient aller plus
loin une visite commentée qui est prévue
le 4 juin
allez en apprendre un peu plus sur lui
exactement alors on aura peut-être la
chance je m'avance pas trop mon aura
peut-être la chance de la voir madame
castiglioni ce jour là voilà et puis on
se retrouve autour de petits gâteaux et
d'un café pour pour visiter et découvrir
l'exposition après je vais pas présenté
tous les têtes sous lui toutes les
affiches mais j'insiste sur
quelques-unes
et justement ça fait un beau duo avec
madame cécile denis qui elle apporte sa
touche en fait perçu personnel alors je
vous racontais un enjeu sur un mot sur l
généreux on en a parlé vite fait tout à
l'heure l'exposition elle est gérée par
le pôle sauvegarder transmission des
patrimoines j'espère que tout ça est
l'une des maisons où c'est justement de
gérer des fonds comme ceux ci est de les
mettre en valeur j'imagine oui c'est ça
alors ingénierie c'est une agence
départementale qui vient en aide en fait
aux communes rurales et ils viennent en
aide
autour d'eux plutôt le côté expertise et
à l aide à maîtrise d ouvrage et
effectivement il faut savoir que le ps
tp le pôle soda à transmission des
patrimoines
bien qu'il y ait cet apport financier
qui vient du département pour la
restauration
de mobilier d'immobilier voir archives
il ya aussi toute cette expertise
notamment avec nos conservatrice qui ont
aidé les communes et c'est pour cette
raison qu'on continue dans cette voie là
avec cette donation
merci aurore beauté alors luigi
castiglioni se dévoile aux archives
départementales c'est jusqu'au 6 juin
et pour ceux qui ne pourraient pas s'y
rendent la date étant proches les
oeuvres seront aussi exposés en
septembre à l'orangerie du domaine de
madame elisabeth laville de guyancourt a
récompensé les artistes de sa quatrième
édition d'art talent un concours gratuit
ouvert à tous pour une exposition de
leurs oeuvres sous toutes leurs formes
marylène il a pilot et nicolas d'andré
pas de thème chaque artiste est libre
dans sa créativité l'exposition art
talent débuté il ya un mois a pris fin
le 19 mai avec sa traditionnelle remise
des prix c'est la quatrième édition à
chaque fois un invité d'honneur
un jury différent ce qui laisse une
diversité de prix puisque nous avons
trois prix plus le prix public et ça
permet à ce moment là d'avoir une
diversité de talents exposés chaque
année des merveilles différents suivant
les esthétiques du jury à travers ses
peintures cil que questionner dévoile
l'animalité qui sommeille en l'homme
elle est l'invitée d'honneur de
l'édition 2019 y expose sa série human
birds j'étais très honoré c'est une
nouvelle expérience aussi d'être dans un
jury de pouvoir
défendre d art is l'heure des
récompenses est arrivé le versaillais
daniel convenant remporte le prix du
jury avec sa technique originale des
peintures ou bitume présentement on m'a
même déjà parce qu'un pauvre et oblige
il parlait de lui-même et son envie qu
et donc ça ça fait partie 1 présente un
visage sur alice parce qu'avant je
faisais des peintures sociales près de
la ville une peintre évinoise d'origine
italienne
ses paysages réalisés en collant des
papiers de soie parents lui ont été
inspirées au retour d'un voyage en
résidence d'artiste encore et ça me fait
plaisir mais je ne m'attendais
absolument pas donc je tremble encore ça
me fait plaisir que mon travail soit
reconnu et que ça plaise à des gens que
par exemple que je connais pas la ville
entend bien réaliser une cinquième
édition toujours dans cet objectif de
découverte de nouveaux talents pour de
nouvelles expositions et des nouveaux
talents se révèle à magny les hameaux
parce que depuis le 16 mai c'est la
ville vit au rythme des restitutions
culturelle des associations et des
enfants de la ville c'est le festival
les arts font école un mois où se
succèdent spectacles musicaux création
théâtrale ou encore compte c'est un
théâtre d'onde qui a ouvert cette
édition un moment imaginé et interprété
par les élèves de 5e 4 du collège albert
einstein on écoute de leurs professeurs
en projets que nous avons menés depuis à
peu près la fin du premier trimestre sur
en collaboration pardon entre plusieurs
disciplines
donc le français avec madame du peu
la professeure documentaliste aussi est
intervenue et puis nous deux donc en
musique et en arts plastiques à travers
ce projet ils ont pu créer un texte en
français ils ont ils ont pu composer la
musique crée des éleveurs des décors en
arts plastiques est effectivement
apprendre à rechercher exactement une
ambiance dans un ouvrage et le festival
se poursuit sur la connu ce jeudi les cp
et ce1 de l'école louise weiss vous
conte l'histoire de la petite poule
rousse une histoire musicale venue
d'irlande samedi 25 mai partez pour un
voyage musical autour du monde avec
l'association la voix en selle digue en
armes et l'association musicale de la
mérantaise vous pourrez aussi découvrir
la chorale et l'atelier danse du collège
dans promenade
l'opéra à la comédie musicale c'est le 7
juin à la maison de l'environnement et
le 8 juin vous retrouverez ici quand
même pour célébrer leur 26ème fête sur
la scène de l'estaminet
d'autres rendez vous sont à ne pas
manquer sur oman et les âmes où le
festival dure jusqu'au 29 juin pour en
savoir plus direction le site internet
de la ville
c'est la grande fête du cinéma le
festival de cannes se déroule jusqu'au
25 mai 21 films sont en compétition dans
la sélection officielle d'autres dans
les sélections parallèles du festival
certaines de ses productions ont été
financés en partie par la région
ile-de-france accompagnement dans le
cadre du fonds de soutien au cinéma et à
l'audiovisuel au de l'aide après
réalisation le cinéma un secteur porteur
pour la région qui représente le 250
mille emplois le point avec grégory
canal et depuis la croisette les images
sont signés d'alexis garneau et
l'ile-de-france bien présente pour ce
62e festival de cannes cette année seize
films soutenus par la région sont en
lice dans les différentes sélections aux
cannoises alors la région alloue un
budget de plus de 20 millions d'euros
cinéma et à l'audiovisuel c'est un
secteur porteur pour le territoire
ce chiffre en 2010 est 4200 cdi a créé
une progression de 15% par rapport à
l'année précédente ces derniers chiffres
ont été révélés lors d'une conférence de
presse à cannes en présence de la
présidente de la région valérie pécresse
avec valérie pécresse présidente de la
région ile de france bonjour bonjour
donc les derniers chiffres du cinéma de
l'audiovisuel révélé on l'a compris une
année 2007 qui a été une année de
croissance pour le cinéma un autre
chiffre 134 des 188 long métrage
français ont été tournées en ile de
france il ya une vraie volonté d'être
présent ici à cannes pour dire l'île de
france est une région de cinéma bien
entendu nous avons augmenté de 20% nous
aide à la production cinématographique
en ile de france et ça nous permet
d'annoncer une hausse d'emploi de 16 et
demi pour cent plus de cent cinquante
mille emplois dans la filière cinéma en
ile de france ça veut dire que et bien
nous c nous travaillons et grâce à ce
travail d'attractivité pour les films
nous créons des emplois mais dans tous
les domaines
le décor les effets spéciaux les
techniciens du spectacle
nous on fonctionne et des studios parce
que nous sommes le hollywood français il
faut quand même le dire nous avons la
moitié des studios français sont en ile
de france
donc le cinéma je ne suis pas là
uniquement pour parler culture je suis
là aussi pour parler emploi
développement d'une vraie filière
professionnelle en ile-de-france alors
j'aurai l'occasion de rentrer dans le
détail jérémy ray de l'air mais en tout
cas l'une des raisons avancées pour
cette embellie
cette croissance du cinéma c'est le
soutien en tout cas le contexte
financier qui est positif pour la région
ile-de-france donc un soutien de la
région plus de 20 millions d'euros pour
ce budget cinématographique et
audiovisuelle pourquoi c'est important
pour vous de soutenir le cinéma belge
dédié à cause d'eux des emplois créés un
cent cinquante mille emplois ça n'est
pas rien et puis surtout parce que nous
sommes dans protex du bric site haut
notre principal rival c'est londres et
aujourd'hui on peut espérer de la
relocalisation de films britanniques
parce que les aides européennes ne
seront plus attribuable à des films
tournés en grande bretagne et donc eh
bien il derrière le break site financier
il ya aussi le break site audiovisuel et
donc avec film parisse reid jeunes qui
est notre commission du film nous
essayons d'attirer les tournages en
ile-de-france d'attirer les
coproductions internationales
et puis derrière il ya tout le
rayonnement d'île de france parce que
quand vous filmez paris quand vous
filmez là
un beau château dans les yvelines où
quand vous filmez versailles et bien
évidemment ça donne envie aux touristes
de venir est donc derrière il ya les
400000 emplois de la filière touristique
qui peuvent être aussi très impacté
dernière chose il ya seize films
aujourd'hui à cannes qui sont soutenus
par la région ile-de-france qui sont
présents dans les différentes sélections
c'est une aide de la région qui est sur
plusieurs niveaux possibles aussi bien
pour la production l'écriture aussi de
scénario est aussi le post production
c'est ça il ya différents niveaux
oui on aide les films à tous les niveaux
mais ce que je voudrais dire et dont je
suis particulièrement fier c'est que 50%
des films qui ont été aidés par la
région sont des premiers ou des seconds
films c'est à dire que la moitié de
nozay devons à des jeunes cinéastes et
vont les faire émerger et alors avoir
seize films en compétition à cannes avec
des cinéastes qui ont parfois très
jeunes je crois que c'est un immense
succès parce que ce que nous
ambitionnons dette c'est la première
région de la création en europe
merci valérie pécresse est à présent
avec jeremy renner bonjour bonjour vous
êtes le président de la commission du
film d'ile-de-france alors ces chiffres
dévoilés en 2017 à une année de
croissance encore pour le secteur
audiovisuel et cinématographique en
ile-de-france 4200 cdi a créé avec une
progression donc de plus 15%
il ya plusieurs raisons qui ont été
avancées j'évoquais tout à l'heure avec
valérie pécresse le budget de la région
qui peut expliquer cette hausse y aussi
un autre constat c'est que davantage de
productions françaises se relocalise en
france 134 des 188 long métrage
nationaux et ont été en tout cas tournés
dans la région ça c'est aussi une des
raisons avancées
oui exactement c'est ce que vous disiez
à quelques instants c'est à dire que
d'abord les chiffres sont historiquement
bon c'est la deuxième année notamment
consécutive où les chiffres de l'emploi
sont sont très haut
nous en sommes évidemment très
satisfaits et ceci est dû à plusieurs
facteurs
alors évidemment en ile de france on a
un patrimoine naturel
tout le monde nous envie ça soit
versailles la tour eiffel notre dame
et puis il ya l'effet combiné du crédit
d'impôt et du fonds de soutien de la
région ce qui permet aujourd'hui
d'atteindre des chiffres très haut avec
une nouveau au 46 5% qui nous permet
d'atteindre
là le chiffre de 19 mille emplois en cdi
ce qui est un chiffre que nous avions
évidemment pas connu
donc nous en sommes très satisfaits et
nous allons poursuivre dans cette
dynamique
on a parlé des productions françaises
mais il ya aussi un angle internationale
en ile de france l'île de france sait
attirer ces productions étrangères en
2017 60% des films étrangers qui se sont
tournées en france on est long et effet
dans la région bon on vous avait parlé
bien sûr des de la fiscalité avantageuse
il est aussi un atout indéniable du
territoire en termes de lieu de tournage
on pense forcément
le château de versailles vous l'avez
évoqué tout à l'heure il ya plusieurs
possibilités en ile de france
évidemment la région ile de france
comporte 4400 décors qui sont d'ailleurs
référencés par la commission du film sur
un site réservé aux professionnels et ce
qui fait que nous avons un atout naturel
on en parlait tout à l'heure de france
du territoire francilien qui permet en
réalité de pouvoir tourner un film dans
son ensemble parce que comme vous le
savez le territoire francilien est très
diverse
nous pouvons tourner une série une série
ou un film dans un la campagne comme en
zone
urbaine donc c'est assez intéressant
parce qu'on a la diversité que n'ont pas
forcément toutes les régions il ya aussi
un savoir faire français bien en terme
d'animation est aussi d'effets spéciaux
et évidemment nous sommes connus voir
reconnue pour une savoir-faire
franciliens en termes de d'effets
spéciaux
nous avons des écoles qui sont
implantées sur le territoire de l'île de
france et qui font de nous un territoire
leader dans ce domaine une infection n'a
parlé de ces chiffres de 2017 les
perspectives pour l'année 2018 si elles
sont l ipe aspects qui sont très bonnes
nous allons on l'espère confirmé les
chiffres que nous avons vu en 2017 et en
2000 2016 2018 pour les chiffres que
nous avons déjà sont très positifs
permettent de maintenir cette ses taux
historiquement haut historiquement bas
en fonction des taux dont on parle le
loto dont je vous ai parlé tout à
l'heure de 20% de délocalisation alors
qu'il était à 36 il ya quelques années
et le taux de 2018 vous voyez que les
choses évoluent bien merci jeremy renner
merci à vous et je rappelle que vous
êtes le président de la commission du
film d'île de france également
conseiller régional d'île de france
le rendez vous marqué la fin de la
saison du théâtre du vésinet un rendez
vous autour d'un style le jazz
cette année les équipes invite à
découvrir les états unis à travers
différents artistes le point sur cette
édition
[Musique]
c'est peut-être le plus classique des
artistes programmés
pierre christophe quartet fait
redécouvrir erroll garner célèbre
pianiste des années 50 le vésinet jazz
métis festival m remonter aux origines
du style c'est un festival qui a cette
particularité de de vouloir faire mettre
en valeur les groupes de jazz qui
s'inspirent de leurs racines délecte des
traditions des différents bugs quoi
d'afrique soit d'amérique latine soit
des caraïbes et qui en font un jazz
contemporain donc on a des groupes qui
viennent des états unis mais chaque fois
qu'ils puisent dans l'histoire
quatre dates quatre styles pour attirer
amateurs et passionnés famille
individuel au jazz académique succès de
la salsa du spanish harlem orchestra
[Musique]
un moyen de voyager avec lui des grandes
soirées des grandes soirées jazz sur le
grand plateau est aussi le vendredi soir
et le samedi soir c'est une fête dans le
théâtre parce que avant et après il ya
des groupes de musique qui permettent de
de rester avec des amis le san francisco
jazz collective et arat kilo complète
cette nouvelle édition du festival des
artistes venus des quatre coins du monde
pour un aller simple vers les états unis
[Musique]
à la lanterne de rambouillet c'est une
famille qui est attendue les ogres de
barback ils ont sorti en début d'année
un nouvel album amour grise et colas
rouges
le groupe de frères et soeurs est à
écouter samedi 25 mai éradiquée par ses
ratés temps leurs ragots d'écouté
moulinant les deux mains sur pieds sous
terre vers aujourd'hui c'est moins
d'autres desseins
pour les yeux
sentant que tu veux
[Musique]
découragé par ces courageux raciste
en avisant celle en misant pierrot mer
mais aujourd'hui c'est moi qui vous ai
laissé des professeurs décideront qui
vont décidément ça fait mal et j'ai pris
cher en fait je le suis de quoi un
détour par le pays des merveilles à la
merise de trappes alice conte son
histoire une histoire proche de l'oeuvre
de lewis caroll mais aussi très
éloignées la compagnie néerlandaise de
style tu crées une alice multiples
extraits
[Musique]
leurs instruments viennent des quatre
coins du monde des sonorités variées au
service de leur style natural trance
après un premier passage en 2017 hilight
tribe revient à voisins le bretonneux
le groupe se produit le 28 mai prochain
à la salle de la tour de voisins
où
oui
le 24 mai débute la quatrième édition de
tracteurs blues un événement itinérant
et gratuit la scène tirée par un
tracteur s'arrête dans trois communes la
première concernée gayon sur mansion qui
accueillera melvin tel enjeu blanc dit
chip on écoute ces derniers
[Musique]
à la fin du combat quasi way
b gomis
à
pour
un idiot en somme
il a quitté leur mari
c'est la fin de cette étude culture
merci de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine pour un nouveau
numéro
[Musique]